I got some apocalyptic news for you guys
let's go the postmania reports largest
U.S power grid faces level one emergency
as Biden's decarbonization policies take
effect record-breaking temperatures are
hitting all the big cities not to
mention these Canadians are trying to
choke us out you know we got our power
grid our power went out uh uh at our new
facility the power went out it was a
storm though they say on Thursday the
largest U.S power grid operator pjm
interconnection LLC issued a level one
emergency over concerns they would not
be able to maintain adequate power
reserves as customers deal with
scorching temperatures according to
Bloomberg pjm issued a call for all
power plants to operate full capacity to
deal with the increased use of air
conditioners as much of the country went
under a heat advisory
so this is not so much about Biden's
policies it's more so that uh I guess
it's a hot summer it's bloody hot well
what are they saying it's like the
hottest hottest month on record or
something or the hottest day it's
because we didn't pay enough in carbon
taxes last year and therefore you
haven't seen the immediate uh payoff of
increased carbon tax you know what I
love though I love the meme where it's
like the climate change policy
politicians are proof the government can
control the weather
that's funny right
it's it's first of all we can all agree
on the RFK Junior principle pollution is
bad we want to enact policies that
doesn't result in more pollution the
idea that we're going to control carbon
emissions and that's going to have an
immediate effect on the environment okay
if you believe that uh and I'm I'll talk
to Trudeau again if you believe that
crippling the Canadian economy which
represents 1.5 percent of global
emissions is not what you want what you
want to someone who's going to be harder
on China which would have ironically
been not the person that you have in the
white house now in the states so it's
it's it's it's asked backwards from
beginning to end even if you believe the
premises of the uh the client look but I
don't I think that trying to stop people
from producing waste is a misguided
effort they're gonna poop they're gonna
burn stuff to stay warm and to stay cool
you need to reuse the waste it is we
need a global effort to reuse the carbon
dioxide and methane coming out of those
machines true but I I don't think when
people are talking about that type of
reducing waste I'm curious to know like
you know in Canada by the way now you
can't get plastic straws so it's all
this this panel at all at all can't get
plastic coloring so you're getting I
don't know what it's made out of I don't
know what the environmental footprint
it's it's it might be like cornmeal
stuff straws or paper straws are
actually paper so you go get a Starbucks
coffee you better drink it fast because
your straw is not going to last that
should be the new logo hold on what if
we replace straws with cookies you ever
had those cookie straws no I mean it
sounds delicious yeah what they do is
they line it's a cookie and the inside
is lined with chocolate so when you're
drinking it doesn't dissolve the and
then you eat the straw after that and
then you're gonna get diabetes and all
sorts of other issues ah come on just a
cookie what's giving you diabetes is the
is the cookie crumble mocha frap with
two pumps of vanilla and caramel and
caramel on top you know if you just did
a regular cold brew with a cookie straw
you're good but you know maybe yeah but
the thing that I I do wonder I don't
know what the carbon footprint or the
emission footprint is even of the Corn
compressed meal Cutlery or the paper
straws the dye that goes into that like
I don't know what the cost benefit has
been done to determine that this is
better for the environment than that
other than a simple plastic bag this is
paper therefore it's good if you don't
know how the process you know what goes
into that in the first place it could be
even worse like electric cars it could
be even worse than me than gas cards I
think we should ban air conditioners
just outright today yes right now and uh
based I you know what I'm thinking I'm
thinking we want to crank the heat up on
the people who uh don't work who are
entitled who are demanding so my
attitude is like let me tell you if
tomorrow you know aliens came down and
just went like and press the button and
all air conditioners disappeared
I would I would be okay now in all
seriousness a lot of elderly people and
people who are at risk yeah we don't
really want that my point is we have
such luxury and the pollution all the
stuff we're talking about it's typically
not the people listening to this show
it's typically not the people in rooms
like this we're when you come out into
the country what do you what do I what
do I see solar panels generators
chickens septic systems the people who
live outside of cities are living
substantially more sustainable lives
than people in the cities the people in
the cities are overwhelmingly Democrat
voting for policies why it's obvious
they want things and they want to make
sure that everyone has to cut back so
they can maintain their standard of
living it scales up the ultra wealthy
why are so you know we talk about them
buying property on beachfronts and
flying in private jets they say
everyone's got to cut back everyone's
got to cut back because of global
warming what they're really saying is if
you don't cut back I don't get to fly on
my jet you all better cut back so I can
keep flying on my private jet yep
because I'm important my time is
important I'm needed oh because it feels
good gotta spread the word you gotta you
gotta go City to City complaining about
uh carbon emissions we love air
conditioning that's my point and there
are people in these cities who have
everything handed them fresh running
water clean running water Refrigeration
air conditioning and they complain they
deserve more and I'm not saying people
don't deserve to live better lives I'm
just saying like at a certain point you
got a big city it is polluting like
crazy it is concentrating human waste
and not just in the biological but in
the in the in the consumerism
Pharmaceuticals Pharmaceuticals Plastics
people out in the middle of nowhere are
not large contributors to a lot of this
look we have our own eggs people who
live out in the country they're more
likely to have backyard chickens they
don't go and buy plastic cartons of eggs
they are less likely to contribute to
the problem but in these cities they're
voting for policies to force the people
who are doing things right to live
crappier stand so they can maintain
their their awful standards I don't get
I think that the mentality is okay they
want to shut down some power I don't
know what Biden's plan is right now
that's threatening to uh annihilate our
electrical grid but it's like okay too
much too much air conditioning uh but it
requires the pollution to get the air
conditioning so we need to make these
people suffer by turning off their air
conditioning
and I'm not getting this out properly no
this is what I think the Biden mentality
is is like we need less oil burning so
we need these people to take they're
gonna have to suffer they're not going
to get their air conditioning because
the only way for them to get air
conditioning is to create pollution and
the pollution is too dangerous so it's
going to make people use electricity I
don't understand I got solutions for
everybody you know we can build
structures that remain cool that while I
was going to say you're talking in the
big city environment you are talking
about more pavement more heat in and of
itself out and Out in the Country it's
green grass it's still hot but like you
say Tim I mean I noticed a lot of open
windows and clothes drying outside
instead of in dry cleaning in drying
machines whatever they're called I mean
if if we fundamentally changed the way
we build homes and we built down set of
us exactly they'd be they'd be cooler uh
so we have Geo at our studio we have
geothermal heating and cooling
underground tends to be around 50 some
odd degrees so when it's cold outside
you you concentrate heat from
underground and start bringing that in
granted there's a little bit more to it
but uh for our air conditioning it's
ridiculously low energy relative to
compression because all we're doing is
pulling heat from from the room and then
running it underground to dissipate it
where it's cold so it's a lot easier and
cheaper to cool
you could build downward structures and
not need heavy air conditioning in fact
back in the day how would they keep food
cold to preserve it they put in the
basement now it's like it's the craziest
thing that we've abandoned all of that
basic Pantry stuff because we just have
refrigerators it's like well we should
do both I mean we shouldn't get rid of
good traditional practices which save
energy and prolong life just because it
got easier but this is the reality of it
in France people can't ride horses
anymore because we have cars and we say
nobody needs to learn how to ride a
horse anymore well there's a funny it
was a funny meme about cargo ships using
kites to preserve energy and they're
literally doing this kites are very
different from sales but it's a similar
principle uh sales can you can actually
sale I'm not a sailing expert many of
you listening probably know but I know
that you can go like 45 degrees at the
wind and then Tic Tac left and right to
sail you know forward when the wind is
blowing at you that's how you move in
that direction kites more so is what I
was told by a sailing guy they launch
when they're when they have the win at
their backs
why did we ever stop using that simply
because we invented the combustion
engine or the steam engine right we
should absolutely utilize these things
but you know what if uh
my recommendation to people is to learn
where in your life you can do these
things because it cuts your costs like
having your own chickens growing your
own food first of all chickens are great
your chickens put out I was talking to
someone earlier like 10 to 12 eggs a day
no it's like 30. that's yeah we have
many chickens I think when it's hotter
they make more
yeah that's amazing you have an animal
that craps out food that you can eat for
breakfast and they do eat it and then
you crap they eat the bugs and give us
eggs the eggs and they make more like
unless you're eating eggs every day
you're gonna fall behind oh we can't
keep up dude we have 30 employees but
it's like everyone's gonna eat an egg
every day so we made deviled eggs the
other day we had a bunch those are good
by the way yeah very delicious in France
they did a Green it's like a green roof
policy in 2015 of March and it says that
all new commercial buildings need to
either have uh plants on the roof
partially covering the roofs or solar
panels we have places like that in U.S
cities the problem is like Tim was
saying they have large pollution centers
these major cities and each 10 15 story
buildings All Glass and air conditioning
is one of the worst greenhouse gas
contributors so if you do want to do
something stop building All Glass
structures and then trying to cool them
in Miami no makes no sense I have a
theory
I think that a lot of what's going on is
nothing to do with climate change and it
had nothing to do with covet has
everything to do with war
we talked about this during the coveted
lockdowns one of the one of the biggest
things that changed was working from
home
you have a company in New York
major economic hub
a company uh based out of there has a
thousand employees they all work in the
same building one nuclear strike on New
York and that company ceases to exist
massive economic downturn for the for
the United States
they even had that New York PSA about
what to do in the event of a nuclear
strike take a shower wash your clothes
covet happens people spread out leave
cities many wealthier people leave
cities decentralized making it harder to
destroy these companies and begin
working remotely creating a
decentralized network of the US economy
all at the same time we're concerned
about war with China
I've been thinking about this with solar
panels there is one tremendous benefit
to having solar panels we have solar
panels at our new studio that we're
building and we have backup batteries I
do not have them because I'm like I'm
helping the environment I know that it
actually takes more energy to produce
these things than you'll get out with
unless you wait like 30 years I have it
so that I can have power when the power
goes out and the show can go on it's a
backup for the show we have backup
batteries all over the place here
because if it rains the show will not
shut down granted we you know you got to
back up someone backups at the new
facility we have a ridiculous solar
system and a ridiculous backup battery
system so the whole whole building can
be powered for like three days in the
event of a major power outage
the real benefit to solar power is if
there is a strike on on the US or an
attack on the grid
decentralized power generation through
solar or otherwise means we will not be
shut down completely and so I think a
large component of why they're pushing
the stuff is because they don't want to
come out and say we genuinely fear with
the fall of the Petro dollar and the
China and China's potential incursion in
Taiwan and Russia into Ukraine World War
III is on the horizon so y'all better
start prepping for it they don't want
Panic they want economic upturn and they
want policies that will move people into
a direction that will protect us in the
event of a major war I'm not saying
that's the only component I'm saying
it's a large component yeah or natural
disaster something could knock out the
electric or the electric Grid's super
super vulnerable those power lines are
above ground just sitting there out in
the open all those power lines there I
mean they're just Target vulnerable
targets so I see what you're saying in
uh World War II I think it was World War
II well I'll put it this way at a Grand
Central Station there was like a main
Central controller for the railroad
track or something like that for
switching the lines like the and it was
you had to go through a secret message
to find it because they were concerned
that German saboteurs would go in and
shut down Grand Central Station which
would massively disrupt U.S economic
operations which is a key strategy in
winning a war I I learned that story and
I see what's going on and I'm like man
if a new kid's New York this economy is
like like 20 30 off you know oh it's not
it's not a not a crazy idea
um but I think if a nuke hits New York
um the solar panels are for individual
existence I don't think we're worrying
about an economy anymore we're worrying
about you know individual existence but
that's it's like that's a I don't know
an interesting theory is to not be
dependent on the grid honestly but but a
nuke I use that as like a more of a
device not a literal obviously something
catastrophic that hits if it's a another
911 nuclear power plant gets sabotaged
and the grid goes down or you know
earthquake meteor strike EMP solar
flares but I don't I do think
a consideration is Right natural
disasters can we as an economy survive
in these circumstances and I do think a
component is are we weak because we've
centralized too much of our economy and
our grid not weak vulnerable vulnerable
right thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time